and first and
foremost our vaccination campaign remains crucial in mid-april
we were still 25 percent behind the
united states if you look at the number
of adults with
at least one vaccination
today this is only five percent
and the gap is closing more and more
vaccinations mean vaccinations also mean vaccinations,
by the way  freedom the
best proof of this are the 250
million europeans who
have downloaded their cockpit certificate
and are thus able to
move around freely that is a great success
next month we trust in you did you
expect slovenia president you in the
preliminary round slovenia government to
continue the important  work on the move
log files slovenia passerelle
volleyball kukksi.de spk president slovenia
at the lake procession
daniela macedonia sea rescuers proprietary
credibility europe.com it there up noble
task is an application for all lovers
in the xxl use
city has